maybe way alright Latoya how are you hey
welcome back
did the talk we had last time helped you
at all yeah yeah
have you talked about that stuff before
with anyone no never never
and although you think no it's another
world is those your story I like that I
feel better I let it out yeah I think
it's healthier
yeah Lorien realizes it stuff up yeah so
how do you how do you feel about the
life you're living you're down here yeah
do you feel like you were shortchanged
do you feel like you know uh I was so
saying though I mean of all the stories
on my channel yeah want to help so and
so they want to help this person that
person to me you your your story keeps
coming back to my head and saying like
Jesus if anyone got robbed if their
childhood if their wife I mean what was
the happiest moment of your life when I
when I turned 13 and what happened I ran
away from home that was the happiest
moment yeah I feel like a caged animal
like that and it will knock anything
that and walk the book while I was like
there's so much when I got like a book
walk so I have shaking all that book my
steady baby at six years old so I had
second foot in good my home I'm so happy
got a house Kate animal book while it
with here do it with like and didn't go
out his book Wow cuz I ain't gonna do I
can't Adam we know was named at that age
what are you doing [ __ ] sucking in in
so everything I was happy like I was do
everything look Wow a long time home is
what I've been taught is my brother Lucy
wrong I get rang forward cuz I'm the
oldest
you know so I got a book Wow I'm like
yeah I don't I don't know have y'all
don't write a freeway all that are you
see so far really and now your whole
Dana 39
before except universe and where do you
I mean do you do you feel like this is a
low point for you or how do you feel
your life is going
yeah yeah like I said before this no
this is not my life that I want to be
towards me to call the ride the house
kids you know I think so you're living a
life that's very very different from
what you yeah boy Waldo I'd me one more
let's see okay just take her for you my
my but you know Marty my but I think you
know I I don't know Longview nothing
drink beer not my bottle
oh you never you know I just feel like
you like hit my when I'm doing it don't
get personal
now go playing good mom you why I be you
know while I go home on my hair I'll do
you mean another house standing on the
scene before Saudis and daddies and you
know I rose horn stuck in [ __ ] la no
come on mom my auntie's you know telling
me it's like everywhere around you let
you down
yeah come on going well done my Oh God
machine Montgomery except your
grandmother lady seen it seemed she she
had my back
she didn't Tina endowed me she put me
down he don't you believe me
well mom buddy in him my third guy raped
me I told mom he know she said one thing
you're saying was he was saying he was
all know he said that his name was it
wrong
you're right you don't want to think we
know any [ __ ] you're saying [ __ ] he
don't want you no I'm just saying [ __ ]
she said that more I think he made me he
said no he won't you think was it why
you think the old are actually six to
ten years old eight you look so my
grandma he was doing T my back I'm just
one rosetta congeal away what would make
you happy today
honey leo gonna part with my old place
not not him
you know I'm having a box anything but
hey I'm just high living grow now but
you think there's something happening
today being by moving the key like
shaking the car no we're gonna have our
breast you know
moment of a key you know she like that
no formula okay okay
because they can't let the pan know for
future but not true they're not true
that we touched me my breasts they bring
back memories of past but still I take
my breath not true you can't say happy
that's not true you can see the same
path the path oh you know whatever the
future you can't dance it's not true
pass the [ __ ] food rub Peggle I do
the future you know no no no I say well
I keep touch me you can't do this can't
do that to me rules and it's gonna be
either prostitute
you know anything I know rules like my
paying you to [ __ ] up
yeah an open the rules like hit up TV
okay they can't how the rules like [ __ ]
do that you can hurt like that
it killed like that huge this is fading
money then you'll say he says we can't
do it here at you know you know it's a
great little cute I think like be like
me [ __ ] up everybody cuz I can't tell
my team does my [ __ ] can't touch this
can't touch that let me paint money
already you know they take money man I
want to fight then I'm off then I can
you met me
yeah is there anyone around you in your
life that you feel like they're not
taking trying to take advantage of you
yeah yeah okay no no no nobody when we
know or not if they happen to know don't
having a woman I wanna know I think
about if we her me Oh close them you
know everybody they're closing me do it
like this
oh my lab which is about all my life who
would proceed is gonna lie on retreat oh
oh no team people clean up a Juba all my
life you know fair that right she's
about all I would you so bad all my life
to will personally good my life I would
away on are treating I wanna listen to
me like [ __ ] so you go to me on retreat
you know why I don't believe it you know
well my mom Plus isn't it's you know my
mom was gonna give it every year one day
but you know it's oh no all right no
clue that's gonna watch me think mom why
do you talk [ __ ] what have you I see
what no I don't know good daughter you
know what the school did he had me do I
didn't roll and listen wrong word not
like Gucci like I was treated you know
I'll sue dog like that
I'll do a dog like that how do we will
keep my stomach you know this is almost
like what you need is a new childhood
you know just go back you know look
sleep it is written I dream it I feel
better
I'm dream you know if I go sleep in a
dream I'd rather die you know this is
the whole time dream life it's dreamy
way that I'll be happy
oh not a [ __ ] how can you wake up and
you're looking on the street and people
are treating your family all right
I don't know our days ago this game
no no no sleepovers all right ease the
pain a boy though you're broke hop sky
ride a bike how do you ride a bike I
don't know right see the other all right
that's good another all right a little
bit strong but my life wasn't
I don't know skate I'll bring one knee I
swing a dragon I'll be do you drive a
car oh oh no nothing that I do
all right this [ __ ] stuff is it
that's all oh good of that is it I'm
good I'll get her I pass it all right
everything else on her
why not cook I'll cook over you could my
Oh make that yeah but here my girl I
cook with you dog
come here boy here come here know what a
hot wire
Munna I don't think over here I'm
calling from here the wire now - [ __ ]
nothing yeah that one boys no I'm doing
for me for anybody no no kids I'm gonna
[ __ ] cuz I don't know I wouldn't try to
do it so how does he'll know I were
talking to do you know saw the [ __ ]
morning I don't know he tried to use my
phone that's all I know oh no no no hot
skies no set up on or ham or no [ __ ]
that grandfather knew was growing up no
no I'm not addressing a lot of nothing
this is something fun that's it that's
all a recycle that's it no no this man
who don't say I had a hard life
no my life is hard can't think parent
wound up they had the hospital I have
[ __ ] growing up but hard time puny the
community centers it appreciate what
they have and everything ok have [ __ ]
your parents are mice were enemies no
parent hate me you know don't know if it
was zone come on my dad Hertford cuz I
don't anymore and I knew that and I'm
gonna do what y'all because this and I
do job me [ __ ] up in the family got
Louise getting [ __ ] all these y'all
is this I'm gonna do and I do that never
do we as he won't take long before you
know it's not the problem you have hope
of your life ever becoming peaceful and
happy new but you have hope book yeah
because have memories of stupid [ __ ]
happen to me everybody happy about all
my life alright nobody
so we love her oh wait I do I it cuz I
don t know where are you good nice to me
I'm a big a big guys and I mean I'd like
a nice guy
nice gotta take care of me but I'm sweet
over this whole baby oh I fear nobody
nobody's day
oh you know my GU I would be so bad
except oh no oh don't he don't worry
Harvey it's accepted a good week so I
was talking about all my life you know
it's hard we set it up in this [ __ ]
right everyone we're going to me what
why do the way you were talking about
[ __ ] you days I'm gonna day you know
oh oh this is how my head for a face
with my name and I fall get over it Iran
you know everyone says you only she
don't do that to me seemed like she to
others like a queen key my mother every
to food just to shock it up super food
to a house you would pay less you'd ever
do super good super good level to do
shopping getting close alright I'm gonna
worry I were having their shoes so [ __ ]
news you today right did you rush me
pick my shoes out the neck is a daytime
will rush me give us there's a shop
around
we can't let all the cameras a [ __ ] you
do you like [ __ ] huh
you know what happy but go better happy
moreover not go ahead but run with a
banner a be a little baby boy to W do
the boys so welcome a bear happy if he
can you know do you believe in God not
really
because when I listen your story not
really no not really
it's hard for me to believe I know I
don't know because every oh my god oh my
god never want to be like well nobody
would he wait while it got a why do you
like this my gosh I go to that guy I
don't even got a lot of you guys like
that was eye-opening I don't need a
goddamn guy yeah but I love China gonna
[ __ ] over a child we let it rape little
but I can't God would not allow [ __ ]
that no I don't even got okay everybody
know I know God would I like to happen
to a child and there was a god Oh bleep
nobody but I can't see I don't know iw
God
oh you think oh you like you the God and
I said I'll be the guy didn't know I
know I know
does it
it's crazy
Zoe knows today's I wanna stay you know
uni oh no oh no y-you know as no I don't
know why [ __ ] tell what it comes even
ate it if I follow
oh wow just go what I knew I had to do I
would have I knew I was doing so it's
good idea I think when writing I
struggle of ravary school know I draw
rice a day and I could definitely go
with artists I draw the draw here might
be drawing you know what will be drawing
nobody i draw me i draw up missing okay
but you draw no but we do I say I do
easy drama something no no no any worry
well get you having you at five you know
me I need oh excuse me
no but you know what I draw the
coordinators still like you know I like
you I know Stewie oh yes I spoke both no
pain oh you know yeah
oh I know before according you to
quadrant quadrant we were happy you know
very happy you know maybe you know my
give me your key Oh a noble he does your
good night hoping he'll be okay yeah oh
no
that's the same guy say my little only
water that's Jane
see it's saved he was a little things
they say ashamed on taste alone thing
but okay we have monthly ticket sent me
Shinseki geez nobody taking 61 woman to
go work what is it ed ago you know Cece
swimming and rocks where you know did I
but of course you know nobody think the
places were all that fun I put hair cut
out early while I'm up high you know
move on Loki anymore I'm done sorry doc
thank you so much